[music playing]
At that point in
time, my main mission,
get it back to Australia.
We bought a whole
heap of crystal meth
from Zack's suppliers, big
SnapLock bags of drugs.
And we bought a whole
heap of gift sets
that had bath salts in them.
There was a process.
We would have to make sure that
we had gloves on, hairnets.
Then we'd lay out
plastic because we
didn't want any kind of evidence
left, no fingerprints, no DNA.
And we were naked.
It's like open heart surgery.
Take the soap out,
separate it all.
With screw jars,
they have, like,
the plastic around the side.
I would cut that plastic,
empty the contents,
like, into a bowl, weigh
it, making sure that match
the weight of it on the jar.
I don't want any residue
on the outside of the jar.
I would get a very
fine blowtorch
and I'd seal it, put all
the stuff back into the box.
It looks as about as
not tampered with as I
could possibly make it.
Once the product was perfect,
it got shipped with other items
that had to go out.
So it all looked part
of the same parcel
with my company
name on the back.
See ya.
These packages
would get tracked.
Once we knew it got
there a few days later,
we were heaps excited about it.
Then the money would be wired.
The job was done.
We started sending packages
on a regular basis.
It worked out to be
about $320,000 a month.
It wasn't going to be
forever, and then I
could legitimize myself
and focus on my modeling.
I'd be in front of the camera,
boom, in my mind, I'm like, oh,
got to get a gift set today
that had bath salts in them.
And that's what I'm
thinking as I'm getting
told to pull my midsection in.
I lived a double life.
By day, I'm a swimsuit model
gracing the pages of magazines,
nighttime I'm packaging
drugs to send overseas.
Those two worlds for
me were very real
and I couldn't
have them collide.
I now had so much
money, it's obscene.
I could just walk into
anywhere, purchase
whatever I wanted
at whatever time,
and not even blink an eyelid.
I walked around
thinking I was the best
thing since sliced bread.
What are you doing today?
We're going to go and watch a
show in Broadway in New York.
I'm going to book a flight now.
Can't get a flight?
Let's get a G6.
It's-- yeah.
I wish in my mind now that
I looked at those times
and thought, that
could send me to jail
for the rest of my life.
But I didn't know any different.
When you have financial
freedom like that,
if you have no
discipline, you run amok.
And that's pretty
much what happened.
I wasn't turning up for
shoots, drugs were rife.
It wasn't a cause of my demise,
but we got out of control.
I thought, the power, the
success, and the money,
and I would be happy
for once in my life.
And I wasn't.
I was not fulfilled.
I had not found love.
I was so hollow and empty.
Why can't I just go
into the supermarket
and then there'd be,
like, a can of, like, love
and a can of family,
and I'll buy all that
and I'll be right, because
I knew what was missing,
you know.
[music playing]